Did you know that the world is ruled by one
company?
Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing Company
may not be a household name.
But its chips are everywhere.
In iPhones, air conditioning units, smart
doorbells, computers, cars, F-35 fighter jets,
and even NASA’s Perseverance Rover that
landed on Mars.
The reason automakers haven’t been making
enough cars is because of a shortage of these
sophisticated chips that power functions like
braking.
Semiconductor chips are the new “oil”
in terms of our dependence on them.
One company pretty much has a global monopoly.
Nestled on the northwest coast of Taiwan,
TSMC produces 92% of the most advanced chips
in the world.
It’s one of only two companies that mass
produces chips below 10 nanometers, the other
being Samsung.
Nanometer refers to the length of a transistor
- TINY switches 10,000 times thinner than
a human hair that control electric currents.
One nanometer is equal to one billionth of
a meter.
The smaller the transistor, the more that
can be crammed together.
The more transistors you have, the better
the chip, and the more powerful your computer
will be.
When House Speaker Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan
in August 2022, she made it a point to meet
with TSMC Chairman Mark Liu - a sign of just
how important the company is.
Beijing spent weeks telling Pelosi not to
go to Taiwan, an island that Chinese President
Xi Jinping believes is a breakaway province
and has threatened to invade.
In light of Pelosi’s visit, Beijing sanctioned
Taiwan by suspending imports of citrus fruits
and fish.
Of course, Beijing did NOT ban Taiwanese semiconductors
because it relies on them like everyone else.
Semiconductors have become a key part of the
tech rivalry between the U.S. and China.
There are concerns that an invasion of Taiwan
by China could choke off the supply of these
cutting-edge chips to the rest of the world
and give Beijing control of this essential
technology.
So, how did Taiwan Semiconductor become so
dominant?
The fundamental technology was actually invented
in America and gave Silicon Valley its name
- as most chips are created with silicon.
In the nineties, the U.S. manufactured a third
of the world’s chips.
Today?
None of the advanced chips is made in the
USA.
Companies like Intel used to build and design
chips in-house.
But beginning in the 1980s, American firms
started to struggle against competition from
Japanese companies, so they outsourced some
parts of their business that were draining
their profits, including the expensive factories
that produce semiconductor chips.
Morris Chang noticed this trend and took advantage
of it.
He was born in China and in 1949, he moved
to the States where he eventually earned a
Ph.D. in electrical engineering from Stanford.
He spent 25 years rising through the ranks
of Texas Instruments before the Taiwanese
government offered him a chance to develop
its semiconductor industry.
Chang realized that there was a great opportunity
to create a new company focused solely on
making chips that could supply all needs.
In 1987, TSMC was born.
Chang initially priced the chips at a loss
to capture a larger market share in the hopes
that costs would eventually be reduced enough
to generate a profit.
His strategy paid off, big time.
The world’s largest tech companies all rely
on TSMC: Apple, Intel, Qualcomm, AMD, Nvidia,
Chinese tech giant Huawei, and Tesla.
Manufacturing semiconductor chips that are
the size of a fingernail is crazy difficult.
Each tiny chip is packed with as many as 50
billion transistors.
The process begins by cutting silicon wafers
- thin slices of semiconductors that kind
of look like shiny mirrors - into individual
chips.
Employees must wear protective gear when handling
them.
If even a speck of dust falls onto a wafer,
the entire batch risks being ruined.
The chips are made by etching tiny patterns
across the wafer, layer upon layer.
To create the layers, the wafer is coated
with a light-sensitive chemical.
It’s kind of like layering a cake, except
in this case the cake has 75 layers and takes
three months to make.
The layers are connected by copper wires that
carry electrical power.
The entire process is daunting and TSMC has
the undisputed edge.
But things are getting complicated as it finds
itself caught in the middle of a tug of war
between the two superpowers.
In August, President Biden signed the CHIPS
Act into law which bans companies that receive
American subsidies from manufacturing sophisticated
chips for China, any that are below 28 nanometers.
Washington is offering $52 billion in subsidies
to encourage manufacturers like TSMC to build
semiconductors plants in the U.S.
One is scheduled to open in Arizona in 2024,
which TSMC previewed on its LinkedIn page.
But it will still represent only a small sliver
of global chip production.
At the same time, Chinese chip innovation
is growing by leaps and bounds.
In 2020, Chinese firms were still struggling
to get below 40 nanometers.
Today, leading Chinese chip company SMIC is
said to have successfully made a 7-nanometer
chip.
Researchers at a firm called TechInsights
say the chip was made for crypto mining.
China has made it a strategic priority to
boost its domestic semiconductor industry,
showering Chinese chip firms with incentives,
including exempting them from paying corporate
income tax for ten years if they make the
most sophisticated chips.
Still, for now, Taiwan Semiconductor is the
most important chip manufacturer in the world.
It’s producing chips that are 2 nanometers
smaller than China and vows to start manufacturing
ultra-advanced 2-nanometer chips by 2025.
That means your iPhone would last four days
without needing a charge.
China needs TSMC just as much as the United
States does.
As geopolitical tensions rise, Taiwan Semiconductors'
importance on the world stage may be the island’s
greatest protection against any possible invasion.
If you’d like to learn how to make videos
like these, Skillshare is an incredible way
to pick up new skills and you can try it out
for FREE.
I initially joined Skillshare more than a
year ago to learn how to make better thumbnails
for my videos.
And then I happened to stumble upon another
one of Polymatter’s classes on how to make
animated videos and I’ve been pretty addicted
ever since.
There’s something for everyone no matter
your interests.
You can learn how to edit videos…
or improve your editing skills if you already
have some experience.
You can get tips on how to speak confidently
on camera.
Or develop good productivity habits.
Skillshare is great for both your hobbies
and your business.
You can join me on Skillshare for a FREE trial
by clicking on my custom link in the description.
The first 1,000 people to use the link will
get a 1-month free trial of Skillshare.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.